هزت اصوات المعارضه شوارع مدن ايرانيه عده
ليصلر اضطدادها لشوارع عواصم غربيه
[موسيقى]
ونفوذه نظام يعلم حجم الرفض له داخليا قد
يكون بامكانه قموعها بوسائل وحشيه لكنه
بات الان يستخدم ذات الاسلوب في قمععارضه
خارجيه امر تدركه وتحذر منه الحكومات
الغربيه
بشكل خاص اولئك الصحفيين الشجاع الذين
كشفوا ما تفعله الحكومه بحق الايراني تجب
حمايه المراسلين الذين يوفقون هذه
الاحتجاجات وستتم حمايتهم في بريطانيا لم
يكن هذا التحذير الاول من بريطانيا من خطر
التهديد الايراني قبله اتهم المدير العام
لجهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه البريطانيه
نظام الايراني بمحاوله مع في بريطانيا
مشيرا الى قيام الاستخبارات الايرانيه ب
10 محاولات على الاقل
في امريكا كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان
ايران استعنت بصوره خفيه بمحققين امريكيين
خاصين لا يعلمون حقيقه العمل المطلوب منهم
او الجهه التي تقف وراءها لمتابعه وملاحقه
المعارضين الموجودين على الاراضي
الامريكيه ربما الدليل الاكبر الذي استندت
عليه الصحيفه ما حدث مع الصحفيه المعارضه
نصيحه
كلفته بملاحقه شخص اجنبي من قبل عميل غير
امريكي وبعد ايام من المراقبه اتصل عملاء
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وقالوا انني
اعمل دون قصد لخدمه المخابرات الايرانيه
في مهمه لمراقبه الصحفيه المعارضه مسيحه
علينا نجاد
تزوجت النظام الايراني خارج حدوده قائمه
تتسع يوما بعد يوم في كندا اعلن جهاز
الاستخبارات الكنديه انه يحقق في تهديدات
بالقتل بناء على معلومات ذات مصداقيه
اطلقتها ايران ضد اشخاص على الارض الكنديه
هذه الانشطه الايرانيه الغذائيه والتدخل
الاجنبي يقود في نهايه المطاف اما كندا
والكنديين فضلا عن قيام من الديمقراطيه
وسيادتنا
استراتيجيه اسكره المعارضين الايرانيه
بالصوره فجه وعلانيه باتت محطه انظار
الدول الغربيه
الايراني العابره